hello luke and luke
i'm sure you're hearing that all day
right people just saying luke and luke
and luke
it's lovely i'm actually starting to
lose sense of who i am actually
maybe that's me
someone didn't ask me the other day
someone said luke thompson i was like no
no luke
you're mad yeah so no i haven't we have
a compliment
yeah
so congratulations i mean season one was
such a massive hit as you know and
season two
really lived up to season one so
congratulations to both of you uh i
really really enjoyed it uh and
especially
you know i'm trying to figure out why
this generation loves the show so much
because you're looking for a suitable
match you talk about marriage i mean
why does it resonate with viewers
i think the the biggest attraction is
that it it takes something that feels
quite traditional and quite formal which
is like regency england
and actually makes it very relatable and
and in a way that obviously feels
deliberately you know trying to be able
to give it a bit of a modern flavor but
also is touching on the fact that
the past is not that different from the
present you know it's all very well sort
of saying oh well everything was so
romantic and
precious and like chased at that time
and it was all about like lovely little
letters and thrills and all that kind of
stuff and actually of course that was
part of it but actually you know people
don't change that much like i i don't
see sort of you know
tender dating apps is any different from
walking around a ballroom with your
dance cards trying to find you know like
it's no it's no difference i think
people are
quiet i think delighted that that world
suddenly can feel much closer to us i
think that's such a lovely thing to feel
included in that world which can feel a
little bit formal and a little bit
distant right right
you know and it's also about love right
we really do learn about that you know
to the mom who you're trying to get
anthony to look for love uh so how do
you define love
you know what i think i don't know about
defining but what i found so um
interesting about the the first season
is that idea that you choose that you
can choose to follow do you choose to
fall in love with someone there's that
really lovely it's definitely sort of
saying to simon like you know you can
choose to love me as much as i love you
and i i just find that really
interesting because i think we sort of
think of love as something quite sort of
passive like you know you fall in love
yeah actually it's incredibly active
like it's a very active thing and i
think this idea it's more an idea that
it's sort of you know you can't help but
dot dot dot but actually you do do get
that feeling though right when you're
falling in love of course you do it's
like yeah okay okay so love is real
oh yeah
but i think it's just that it's active
you know like i think it's such a lovely
idea that it's like something that you
work on yeah and i think what's great
about our show is that it shows the all
the different types of love like we have
our family relationships right siblings
between mother and son between and also
even between relationships and how they
grow and like for example we've seen
daphne and simon in season one and it's
like the the burning for each other like
almost almost immediately and then over
season two we get to see this like
tension grow and honestly from watching
it it's just incredible to see that that
those two kind of go against each other
for the whole season that's right and
then you know even our characters alone
how we sort of navigate our way through
love and and how different it is to the
siblings even though we've had exactly
the same upbringing it's really like
interesting to explore
that's a really good point and and i
have to say it's really steamy uh season
one was exciting and season two is even
more passionate uh did you tell your
friends and family about the show i mean
you'd say it's a period piece you're
like okay whatever uh but it's it's
steaming guys like how do people react
they're surely used to it by now right
yeah
they know what they know what's coming
exactly
i had a question the other day which was
what's a film or series you wouldn't
want to watch with your nan and i think
probably bridgeton season one episode
four and five is probably
five or five a long trip to the toilet
yes
you know one of the great things about
lady whistle down is that we kind of
figure her out a little bit more this
season so my question to you what is
some gossip that you follow right now
that's in the entertainment news
oh god i don't really follow it i'm so
clueless i know nothing that's going on
yeah maybe but maybe what we need is we
need we need a lady whistle down
we need nicola maybe to sort of help us
out although she is a good source of
information actually she is
she's like she's very similar in in in
aspects of her character like good lady
whistle down she gets the gossip she
stays on top of it she's like the social
media queen at work maybe we can pick
this as a moment just say nicola help us
yeah
you know
have some juice yeah
oh you guys are awesome congratulations
on season two people are going to
absolutely love it so thanks for making
it and i really enjoyed the diversity in
the show as well so thank you for that
as well thank you thank you very much
thanks everyone